Now added frequencies to my right program are two hours each for a total of four hours.
I guess this is something that I should do during the day. Is that what you would
tend to be to do every day? Thank you. So yes, if I give you some extra frequencies,
let's say I send you a flash drive after a cheek swab test with a short program like a two-hour
program. Yes, that's just to do during the day if you have time. So you have to do them every day.
No. If you're just sitting watching TV or reading a book or something, should you be running the right?
Well, it probably depends on how ill you are. But, you know, if you feel like you're at a fairly
good state of remission, maybe you're not doing the right foot all during the day. You're only doing it
at night. That's me right now. But if you feel like you're not doing well right now or you're not
in a state of remission yet, then during the day, you should be running day programs too if you have
time. And certainly have to keep that balance between living your day and functioning and be with your
family and being alive. But if you're going to be sitting and reading, then you should run those
short programs.